welcome to this video against eirick
eirick G Erica gulickson okay
I am from Norway and played him once and
won the game yeah maybe if he allows
women to play the Embraer again recently
did that that's probably the line I'm
going to play instead of my chigorin but
I have not really studied it yet in any
kind of reasonable detail this sometimes
the brass kind of it's not a passive
line that's the wrong word but sometimes
it's some not so clear what like some
planets do I go c5 here I can't probably
be like can't play that okay now we know
is closing the position so point is here
in four might be awkward okay he doesn't
do that at all okay so shutting shutting
down there
yeah I'm not ideally placed here form
for f5 that's that's Klien you see going
for f4 it looks it really looks like
that so let's try to be prepared that I
did not expect it it's not an uncommon
idea I still did not well I did not
think of this as a serious option I
would love to get Bishop f6 to g5 and
Bishop f6 g5 Bishop e7 mmm that's not
good okay I know it sounds it looks to
be yet but the situation has changed I
have to go back there I think if he goes
g5 I'm going to play f6 and now I'm
happily a three is a that I did not
expect because now I'm really in good
shape here on the dark squares
yeah check keeping my keep it simple
attitude now it's difficult to do
something actively I mean Black has no
problems anyway but it's difficult to do
something yeah exactly
situation is very much very much closed
so what am I going to do Knight f6 rook
edge did have some some moves that I can
definitely play but doing doing
something active it's another matter so
if I want to do something I probably one
can take gauge aid the only kind of
breaks f5 and he's on that like a
million times
we're routing that to t7 first and then
or to c8 and now and then see from here
it says something that I can do to try
to place some kind of age five but it
will never need to to anything maybe
double them and then see I can't do that
you cannot play a four I can take 97 you
need any way forward now I can move the
king of I want
yeah it's simply not leading anywhere
anywhere ever laughs is there some way
to do that it's so close them it's so
close disposition wondering can I
somehow we would the night to g7 or
something that's not really doing doing
much but I can try that I'm not sure if
this is a good idea to try anything here
maybe it provokes him to do something
but I don't know if this is objectively
a good idea my D is 97 and trying to
play h5 maybe it's very strange very
strange idea
it's still a complete draw but what can
you do
you would people close the business here
with with chief form any tricks any kind
of trick I guess not
draw offered game but it was just too
closed has really no way forward there
yeah well yeah I said that I found this
a bit strange how he played that that
you allowed this is it does it's strange
in a way because it gives up any kind of
hope for white but I cannot I cannot do
any section maybe maybe without the
Queen's yeah here that's just the chance
to dead position L it can absolutely do
nothing it's so closed uh yeah and five
is the only kind of break maybe I could
have tried to prepare that but it's it's
a draw what can you do can cannot do
magic in any position or whatever it's
simply some sometimes it is simply just
wrong and no way forward yeah not the
most exciting game ever thanks for
watching guys